I put my protein shake down some
place
and now I can't find it!
Listen, I'm sorry,
but I told your friends
that they were making a little
too much noise--
Those aren't my friends
anymore, Dad.
I don't need friends.
I'm perfect.
They just drummed louder,
you know?
So I--I called the police
to file a noise complaint.
The police?
Dad, the police
are weaklings.
They can't do anything.
Watch this.
[growls]
I have already told
you to be quiet!
(Forrest, voice-over)
Artificially elevated levels
of testosterone
may be useful for short-term
muscle gain,
but not for
conflict resolution.
[yells]
This is ending now!
One, two,
three, four, five, six.
Evict the outcast!
Evict him.
I have achieved perfection
in body and mind!
- I am the ultimate man!
all: Five, six.
I will destroy everything
you have built,
starting with this
stupid tambourines!
- And the these stupid drums!
- Hey! Hey! Not the bongos.
This flag used to stand
for something beautiful!
I want you
off my dad's property!
Would you please just stop?
Stop this!
(Forrest, voice-over)
As I rampaged against
my ex-girlfriend
and her heavily armed
followers,
the police my dad
called arrived on the scene.
Drop it now!
Drop it!
(Forrest, voice-over)
They were joined by members
of the FBI cult squad.
As they pulled out their guns
on Mrs. Greenfield's militia,
I pulled out the last weapon
I had at my disposal.
Look upon my works
and despair!
- Oh--Oh, God!
- Put down the weapon!
Oh God, oh God,
oh God.
(Forrest, voice-over)
I do not know who fired first,
or how the horrible chaos began.
But clearly, I had to get
out of there--and fast.
- What are you doing?
- All right, all right,
all right, all right--
Oh God!
- I can't find my--
- No! No! No! Ahh!
Protect the space ark!
(Officer)
Drop it now! Drop it!
Officer! Don't shoot
the orange Hulk!
He's a good boy!
Oh, God.
Oh God, oh God!
(Father) He's really sweet!
- Dad!
Forrest, I love you!
(Officer)
Down! Drop the gun!
- Dad!
- Oh!!
- Put down the weapon!
Die, monsters, die!
Oh, no! God, no! Oh!
We got to get out of here.
- What?
- Don't look. Don't look.
- They blew up what?
- Don't look at the house.
- Don't look at--why?
- Don't look at it.
Ahh! No!
- Not again!
- We got to go!
(Forrest, voice-over)
All this time later,
I'm still coming to terms
with the horror
of what happened
in that field.
How did my quest
for the perfect body
cost so many other people
their bodies?
It is, by far,
the most terrible experience
this show has subjected me to.